ok google informazioni su barbara d'urso
grazie
suona mad world su spotify bella tutti
ragazzi ovviamente questo video io sono
fa vj oggi siamo su venerdì 13 è un
video che ho registrato con fascia che
va fatto uscire sul suo canale dalla mio
punto di vista di euro jason ne ho fatto
cose incredibili
vi lascio al video perché merita un
sacco buona visione
eccolo lì attenzione e forse siamo noi
potremmo essere noi
il classico g vediamo insieme attenzione
e pazienza amici amici di amici arrivo
ma sai che non volevo ma oggi non volevo
fare non ci avevo voglia detto no va
bene oggi faccia basta
ho già la facciata e presto ragazzi sto
arrivando
io mi chiudo a chiave nell'armadio
chiariti nella magica ma se ci fosse una
macchina buongiorno non sono io sono io
osate ho sentito urlare gente ora questo
è scemo e che mi volevo chiudere nella
non ha una mira veramente che mentre
spazio madonna che chi male che non è
cosa che entrò in ottava sua mamma mia
che male amici amici
e vabbè cosa fa non c'era il campanello
quindi devo crearmi la dell'apertura
vabbè
e male aveva distratto la factory del
[Musica]
aspetto che lo ammazzo
ma stavolta lo guardo lo stage ai
guardavo amore bene ma adesso lo ammazzo
c'è neanche la picchiata il summer ma
come aveva sentito e veloce ai a chi è
stato pesante questo allora io me ne
vado a cercare un arma comunque facciamo
sì che laddove passato come sei passato
ma io non ho mai visto quella panda 4x4
andare per i posti mai visto io l'ho
sempre visto schiantarsi questa macchina
per fermati e divertentissimo dovrei
andati in germania prendimi trials usa
era divertenti sono cina
[Musica]
e stato bellissimo allora basta
il conducente che sta morendo un po la
vita sa che è morta
mi sa che sta morendo anche l'altro
lascia infatti fuori due è stato
benissimo
no non ho preso la curano è stato
proprio divertente amica adesso c'è
quello del jersey shore assaggiati sul
fascino
sto solo cercando di aiutare i miei
amici e che ho guardato prima nelle
pazienti jarvis rotto le balle è morta
era morto migliorato la il jumbo del da
dove è partito va bene partecierà forte
c'era il signor ignoranti sopravviverà
[Musica]
mancato mancato un contagio scappare ma
lo vede non fossero le maschera due
minuti master ma quando sono brutto
oddio sempre pietro
chiedero ragazzi di schifani abbia detto
cazzola
per mangiarsi adesso sa che hai detto
a chi hai detto fascino manchi solo tu
la vedi questa faccia
dammi un bel limone può soltanto essere
suo amico lo giuro un bacio alla
facciamo così se proprio non ricambia
l'amore io le voglio solo dare un bacino
va bene ma mi guardi eccolo combacino
[Musica]
allora può andare
grazie può andare può andare grazie alla
grecia polizia
resisti vedere quando mi spara la
polizia che succeda ma mi hanno sparato
assoluto guardato ucciso raga chi fa la
spia non è figlio di mio nonno mi dire
che se l'unico una possibile sono io
sono un addio ma per una volta tu una
volta invece all'inizio volevamo farti
tutti jackson per una volta che voglia
di giocare insieme in un jason siamo
certo tutte e due
no non ci credo è lorenzo potremmo
patteggiare attaccata alla flashlight
questo cioè costume da bagno a mills ha
la cuccia ce l'ha attaccata dal niente
sono io questo
bocciato il meno bambini aiutano perché
non lo fa entrare da voi io ho preso la
trappola alle vecchie sono gli
attrattori che è male de gaulle ossa mi
piace sto gioco possa riportare a terra
che loro hanno messo allora perché erano
tutte le trappole piazzate tu l'hai
presa tu lo era presa io l'ho presa io
illusioni 1 sali e sale nell'acqua
deficiente le cose della mamma perché in
esso tra comunque non dite male e basta
vai a port calabria trovi una mazza da
baseball ti salva e amico che male che
ti faccio è perché male che si faccia ti
sto facendo malissimo e non ne puoi piu
e ati o atterrato at6 mio adesso grazie
al bacio di un male può diventarlo stato
di lenarda dice
ma incaricato mia cliccato tutta la
schiena per la quale che l'intento
questa ai a stargli lontano manesco ma
come mai jason non esistono più c'è ma
ci sono un pezzo di mollica ormai sono
comunque in cui non mi signore di sessa
no li stanno curioso stanno nell altre
volte ma chi è che mette ste robe in
casa ma chi è deficiente che aveva che
schifo
ma cos'è ma chi è che abita qui ma dai
ma la casa di tommy jarvis questo non
sono praticamente è una cosa ma non
possiamo troika non puoi essere così per
loro dove dove c'è la trappola non può
essere così rinvenuto sei sempre c'è
sesso senza aspetta questo sono io
questo è un fucile ha già trovata campo
sono bravo a sparare visto a me hear me
non è male tanto di sapere a questa ma
cosa vuol dire che fa venire la
posizione di sabrina
ciao amica mi prestito ai vestiti che io
non ce li ho ma per favore si vuol dire
ma che sono a yara
ma cosa sta succedendo ho preso la
poetica fallo fuori dai no non lo dicono
ciao amici i più volte a passaggio come
to the boat di cose ai traghetti the
people ritrattata casa il traghettatore
di anime è preso la marca traghettatori
di anima com down for this bridge e
l'heavy de barca ma voglio ammazzare
tutti farmi un giro in barca con
terlizzi camier wikileaks.org eder ma
questo punto rimorchiato sui grandi 13
sito sito è una tipa questa 6 gen chiusi
power say we are the best player tutto
meno che non sei altro and jason white
mio amico aylwin b cosa in bravo ciao
che era giusto giusto da vedi lei ha
detto ha approvato anche karin aver
ringraziato rimorchiato se venerdì 13 è
così che si conquista la [ __ ] per te
chiamo pietro glielo dico pietro o
rimorchiato su 20 sì una tipa l'ho
salvata e mi ha detto tempio a porta
post è tutto registrato
hai visto sono a casa tua dove mirti
spesso qua ok google
ok google
ok google ok ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto consiglio precisa non mi piace
anche vari social comino della
descrizione ricordatevi che scappare
dalla barca è sempre la soluzione
salvini è d'accordo come al solito si
vide piaciuto sul momento mi piace anche
alla lista ci ha convinto né svizzere
sono precisi chiedere che ci vediamo
capito
ok google soc
[Musica]